[Music]
these people in the restaurant that
we're losing their jobs and watching
their way of life disappear they're
going for anything so in some ways you
had Bernie supporters that voted for
Trump even though economic policies were
hugely different but you're just
grasping for anything that that kind of
makes sense so when you hear a liberal
economist in this case I'm not sure who
it was on Bill Maher but when you hear
this person talk about these
knuckle-draggers or whatever isn't that
also it's almost feeding into that thing
again like these people are so sick and
tired of being abused and beaten and
ridiculed by the system that even if
that guy is right whoever this person is
that they're still doing the very thing
that pushes people to vote potentially
what could be for against their interest
absolutely and I think this is this was
one of the genius parts of Trump's
campaign where he actually understood
that he needed to bring a different
level of respect to the real issues that
these people were facing I think Bernie
did it and I think my sense is that
Bernie actually would have come through
on a lot of these promises but you know
for campaign finance reasons various
other reasons he couldn't push past the
Hillary machine it you know would have
been a much more interesting contest if
it was burning against Trump
but you know regardless of whether or
not Trump actually comes through on any
of these promises I think he's already
giving these people a lot of what
they're looking for just in terms of
respect for their ideas and some
acknowledgment that what they're saying
and what they're seeing is real which I
believe we as liberal economist have not
really come through on yeah because then
you're just saying the same you know
they get belittled and then you're
saying I see you bunch of morons you're
you're getting exactly what you sowed
and it's like well that's not going to
help them come to your side how much of
this do you think is just that systems
just get to this place where this
happened you know a like so in the rest
of the jobs that are going away it's
like any other thing that exists for a
certain amount of time and it doesn't
that there's pride oh no is there an
example in history when when the whole
industry started disappearing but
everyone figured out the way to get out
properly is there any example of that
that you can think of where it was
prepared for people because they
realized that one thing was going away
and something they were going to have to
do something else or is this just the
natural order of things it may be and
you know one of the things that I'm
really interested now we recently moved
from New York to Silicon Valley and one
of the lines of research that I have
been following is someone named Peter
chairman and MIT economist just came out
with this book where he talks about the
dual economy and the dying middle class
of America and he points out that while
we are very focused on the notion of
secular stagnation and how we're not
seeing sufficient growth in the economy
and we're really seeing a stagnation of
real wages especially in especially with
manufacturing sector but what he does
point to is that there is one sector of
the economy that or three sectors of the
economy that have traditionally been
doing really well which is finance
technology and electronics and so even
though much of our focus has been on
secular stagnation we really are doing
well in areas of innovation and areas of
finance in the question for us then is
how do we actually take lessons from
this area and try to bring it to the
rest of the economy more importantly how
do we try to smooth the path of the rest
of the economy so that we can make this
a lot less painful than it might
otherwise be and you know one of the
things that one here is a lot in Silicon
Valley is how do we bring new ideas to
this why don't we start thinking in
terms of basic income because we are
going to be disrupting the job market at
some very serious level we need to make
sure everyone's taken care of less left
leaning economists tend to be very
suspicious at the notion of basic income
because the fear is that we're going to
use this to basically upend our current
welfare systems and if we decide we're
going to give everyone 10,000 a year and
then we're going to forget about them
that's probably not going to do what we
wanted to do so it's really a question
of how do we approach something like
basic income so we make sure we are
taking care of the people that whose
lives were disrupting but regardless you
know we are going to see this huge
change
in the nature of jobs in this country
and we need to be getting ahead of this
to try and think about how do we address
it and you know part of it is that we
need to think about how our company is
structured in Porter the incentive
structure is to the extent that
maximizing shareholder value has been
the driving push for many American
corporations we're going to find
incentives Doulton that are going to
want to encourage globalization and
marginalize workers who are lower down
on the income scale because that's what
improves shareholder value so if we
change some of the incentive structures
around this I do think there's a lot we
can do to actually smooth the transition
but eventually I do think you're right
we're going to see these changes and
it's a question of how do we get ahead
of them yeah it's interesting because a
couple weeks ago I had dr. Mike Munger
from Duke University who's in a
political science professor at Duke or
he's in charge of the the politics
philosophy department I think it's
politics philosophy and Economics
Department and and he's more of a
libertarian but he was making a sort of
libertarian argument for universal basic
income and I've never heard it described
the way you thought that I always would
have thought that left-leaning
economists would have been for it but
it's interesting that you're saying not
necessarily and and he was actually
making the libertarian argument for
universal basic income so there is a lot
of room to to come together with people
of different thinking traditionally in
this regard absolutely which is
something that I you know I really hope
to be able to do now how do we bring
some new economic thinking to the
innovations that we're seeing coming out
of Silicon Valley you know I think basic
income is a disruptive idea but I really
do think we need to play with it and we
need to try and take it on in a way that
we aren't co-opting welfare systems and
you know make sure that we're not using
it to actually disagree I think you
wanted it to completely co-op welfare
since his argument with that the welfare
systems are failing so let's do this
with that money but I can see why well
the question is why both arguments have
very well the question is are you really
going to do this with this money or
you're going to really try and bring in
the disenfranchised and make sure that
they're properly taken care of what are
you going to set your basic income at
you know how are you going to ensure
transition out of it once people go into
the workforce how are you thinking about
you know my point on this is that we
really need to be thinking about the
economics of it when we structure it I'm
not against the idea of universal basic
income I think it may be a solution to
actually handle the fact that we're
going to be seeing a tremendous amount
of disruption in our job market but we
really need to think about how we're
implementing it and how much how much
resource we're going to be willing to
put into this and you know it's
interesting because in Silicon Valley
people really think in terms of an
abundance economy on the East Coast
people still think in terms of scarcity
with capital s small s you know the
notion of economics is built around the
idea of scarcity and you really do have
the ability I think to use some of
what's coming out of Silicon Valley to
start rethinking some of our fundamental
economic notions has automation and
machines and robots and drones and all
that completely change the discussion I
mean are the discussions that economists
are having now widely different than
they were having even five years ago
even though it was obvious that we were
trending in this direction has it just
completely altered the landscape I think
the problem is that it hasn't and I
think it has really I think it's coming
and you know people will do analyses of
how much of the destruction of the
manufacturing sector is coming as a
result of trade as a result of
immigration how much of it is automation
so you know these are the three things
people talk about and it's like you know
what part if it is globalization what
part of it is automation I don't think
we're thinking in terms of how do we get
ahead of this how do we need to change
the conversation because eventually this
is coming and what do we do to position
ourselves for when it comes ya know the
other that's so interesting to me that
it's not being discussed as much as you
think because there's so many people in
Silicon Valley especially that are like
guys this is this is the game changer I
mean there's so many things that I think
are game changes if you look at just
what's happening with cryptocurrencies
you know I think it's really going to
change the nature of
transactions of macroeconomics and I
think we need to be coming up with new
economics to think about that as well so
I think there's a lot of things that
we're going to have to be thinking about
differently underlying it although I
think one does need to you know going
back to the earlier point I think
underlying all of this is going to be
incentives and we really need to think
about how do we build the correct
incentives in so that we're taking care
of people through this entire process so
with all this in mind the politics at
its core does it really just come down
to economics I would imagine as an
economist and you end probably want to
believe that but the more I talk to
economists and think about this stuff I
mean the idea of if you've got a job and
you you know then you can afford to
hopefully have a home whether you're
owning it or renting it and you can put
some food on the table and that
basically takes care of 90% of what we
talk about in the political scheme of
things I think it's true I did warn you
that from the age of 15 this was the way
of you as well don't ask me that's going
to be the answer I do but I actually do
think there's more actually manage
change you want you to learn a little
bit about do it well you know I have
because I think what I'm coming to
realize if I look at what we're what our
current political situation is and I see
the role that identity politics is
taking in our society I do have the
sense that the heart of identity
politics is or the driving force is
really coming from the economics as well
so you know I talked a little bit
earlier about the investment theory of
party competition and just how campaign
finance changed everything and you know
it's become increasingly clear that
money drives elections in a way that we
never really have acknowledged so you
know recent studies done by some of my
colleagues will show that there's almost
a one-to-one correspondence between the
amount of money spent on a congressional
race and whether or not and who wins
that congressional race and if it's
really money that's driving it then you
would imagine that politicians are going
to
have to raise a certain amount of money
which they can't really do with small
donations anymore so as much as we heard
about how Obama raised money through
small donations if you actually look at
what was driving his campaign especially
the second time around there was a lot
of really big corporate finance in there
and if you think about what that does
from the incentive structure of
politicians when they're in power very
very quickly it becomes really expensive
to actually come through on the economic
nationalism that the Democrats
traditionally promised their base so if
you can't actually give them the
economic things that you've promised
them well identity politics is a really
inexpensive way to feed them and you
know my sense what with watching the
increase of this conversation in our
society is that this is really a
distraction this is a way to take
people's focus away from the fact that
they're really unhappy about what's
happening economically and say let's
give you something else to focus on and
you know I think it sort of drew up for
the Democrats this time um and it's
blown up in a way where I think the
identity politics has gotten really
toxic and the economic issues aren't
being addressed either so you know I
really think I'm waiting until the
Democratic Party finally wakes up and
understands that they're just not going
to be able to get away with substituting
identity politics for the real economics
that they need to be providing their
base does in a weird way does that
almost seem too late like they've traded
in it for too long that even though I
would suspect some of the party heads or
the consultants that they bring in or
even the economists that they bring in a
probably going guys this is the losing
game here but you're sort of in so deep
how would you then publicly put a face
on that to be like we got to change what
we're doing here it's tough I mean I
think there's a grappling with that
right now I think they're grappling with
that you know one of the problems is
that you say the even the economists
they bring in the one thing I found
economists to be particularly weak at is
looking
their own incentive structures so the
phrase that my co-author and I have
coined is the economics of economics
who's actually going to look at the
incentive structure of the economist and
if I look at the economics that was
coming out before this last election
economists know that free trade
increasing trade liberalisation is going
to come with a redistributed consequence
and they know that the target the burden
is going to fall very specifically on a
particular group of people so if you
look at what happened with NAFTA NAFTA
had efficiency effects that were
positive but they were really small
compared to the redistributed effects
and in particular the effects on very
specific segments of population
geographically and in terms of
particular manufacturing sectors and
account and the economists working for
the Democratic Party very often were
whitewashing this they weren't being
honest about what they knew would the
redistributed effects of trade and as a
result my sense is that you've got the
system feeding each other is feeding
itself where you know the politicians
are looking for a particular kind of
economics the economists are happy to
feed that to them because that's what's
going to write their paychecks yeah and
so you know no one's willing to actually
stand up and say hey there's a problem
and you know Bernie Sanders actually did
and he had a few economists who actually
came up with his economic plans that
said you know we can make this work and
the backlash amongst mainstream
economists was huge very few people were
really willing to take seriously some
very serious economics that went into
these pans and say yeah there's there's
a real point here there's something
workable here so you know I really think
underlying a lot of this once again is
incentive and in this case I think the
incentives the economy the economist
studying the economy have their own
incentive structure and you especially
the economist studying the economy you
know I think this came to light very
strongly with the 2008 financial crash
where I think we you know the
queen of england apparently walked into
an investment bank and had one question
for the economists there why didn't we
see this coming and you know that simple
question I think has been something that
has driven many of us in the last
several years to say where did we go
wrong as economist and it's really
interesting that economics have been so
hesitant to look at their own incentive
structures in this that that's so
interesting to me because I remember
before the crash I remember being at a
bar with a friend of mine who worked for
Lehman Brothers uh-huh and he was
talking to another guy and it was my
friend Chris and he kept saying this
thing is going to be a disaster you have
no I like I remember and I had no I
don't even know that I ever heard about
it before or realized that there were
any problems even I don't know if I just
wasn't paying attention to that sector
saying but it's so interesting that that
some people knew some people didn't some
people were going to profit off of the
disaster zone
you know that all of those competing
interests just lead us to that's right
and then you look at where it leads us
to with the political interest so if you
look at what happened after the crash
and once Obama was in office it turns
out that you know a lot of the mortgages
that underlay the crisis were really
badly constructed so they really didn't
have even the legal grounds for the
banks to be able to push on foreclosures
and so had the Obama administration
chosen to come down hard on the banks
and force them to negotiate they could
have really prevented a lot of this
foreclosure foreclosure crisis and you
know one of my one of the things I say
today is the Trump is really a symptom
of the problems within the Democratic
Party because I think there was such a
backlash people was so disillusioned
with Obama at the end of what we saw
with the resolution of this crisis yes
we got growth rates back up but if you
look at what a burden the housing crisis
placed on Main Street America because he
really wasn't willing to go after Wall
Street I think it becomes very clear
where this disillusionment is coming
from and you know once again why wasn't
he willing to go after Wall Street well
take a look at where some of those
campaign finance
funds came from so is that sort of the
biggest issue with Obama than that he
was a - you know forget after the cry go
fast forward - after the crash he was a
do term president he could have done
things about campaign finance or at
least talked about it more or I remember
sort of even at the end his last few
months when he was a lame duck he'd
still be headlining $30,000 ahead plate
then saying that the Republicans only
care about money money money and it's
like well you had an opportunity to do
something and I by the way I don't even
begrudge him any of that because they
all do the same freaking thing and a
Republican would have done it too but at
that point he wasn't running for
re-election and perhaps that even hurt
Hillary in some regard oh there's no
question I mean what was Hillary doing
with those goldman sachs talks right i
mean none of this made any sense but
yeah just rewind to 2010 where you know
he didn't do so well in the
congressional elections he realized that
people were really angry about a segment
of the year they got they got banged up
exactly and he realized if it was people
who really angry that no one had
actually paid for this financial crisis
you know bonuses actually went up that
year on Wall Street as opposed to going
down and you know Obama was apparently
shocked that bonuses on Wall Street had
gone up he had the chance to do
something about it he came out with the
Volcker Rule in 2010 but it was so
watered down that even Paul Volcker was
shocked because it really didn't stop
banks from involving themselves with
hedge funds and all of other stuff that
got us to the too-big-to-fail
yes there was so much that could have
been done to actually change our
financial economy so that we do not have
to deal with this kind of crisis in the
future and he didn't do it and then you
know again you just have to ask what was
what was the incentive structure hmm so
one of the things people ask me so
people always say you know why are you
liberal why do you still call yourself a
liberal you sound like a libertarian and
I always try to lay out my liberal cred
but I do say I think if I were 90% of
the things that I believe I haven't
moved at all and I would argue that the
left has moved left and I stayed here I
do think I've shifted a little bit right
economically when it comes to taxes
particularly now that I'm a small
business owner and have employees and
things like that
when you hear someone say that there are
four small taxes and small business and
all of those things as a left-leaning
economist is there something that I
could be missing in in this regard I
think my strongest feeling about this is
if I look at some of the rent seeking
behavior that I believe drives a lot of
how things are structured
institutionally within this country I
see policies where you have the
billionaire class that has a certain
incentive structure that very often is
going to take from the millionaire class
and those below and they're perfectly
willing to redistribute
to the bottom end of the spectrum as
long as it doesn't touch them so you
know it's one thing to talk about taxes
on small business owners it's another
thing to talk about carried interest
right and it's these questions that we
really are not going to be allowed to
touch because the arm the forces behind
wanting to hold those in place are so
powerful financially and economically
yeah so in my specific instance as a
small business owner you don't have any
issue with small taxes or low taxes and
you know I mean we have a progressive
tax system I think it's really important
to me that we have a progressive tax
system you know I think what we really
need to be thinking about is in equality
in this country if you look at the fact
that in the 1970s the top one percent
had something like 10 percent of the
income and it's gone up now to 20
percent of the income the point 1
percent of the economy of our population
is earning eight times as much as it
wasn't we've gone completely crazy with
respect to inequality and I don't think
the problem is the middle class it
really is the billionaire class and you
know the huge distinction we're seeing I
think that's where we need to be looking
at yeah well if I want to put in it this
is my small business is not in this
billionaire class but you know I think
this goes further I think when we think
about the issue of globalization as well
we
be very clear about the fact that
globalization has had very positive
consequences for the developing world so
China was able to raise a tremendous
amount of the number of people out of
poverty because they were able to open
up their manufacturing sector to the
West and the only problem with that is
that we are doing good in terms of
poverty at absolute levels across the
world but who is bearing the brunt of it
it's not the richest people in this
country who are the ones who are all for
free trade it's the lower middle class
and my feeling is you know if you're
willing to actually redistribute your
income that's fine what really bothers
me is that you want policies that you
say are going to help the rest of the
world that are going to fall on the
backs of the lower middle class in this
country yeah all right so we have about
ten minutes left okay I want to talk
about a guy that we both know for just a
moment have you heard of this Erick
Weinstein fella you know this guy that
I'm talking yeah I tend to hang out with
him a pheromone so you are married to
Eric Weinstein putting a side marriage
for just a sec I won't go too deep into
your into your personal marriage but you
guys have done work together I mean real
work together you coming at it really
from from an economists point of view
him coming at it from a mathematical
point of view and you've sort of married
these these two ideas so can you I guess
time that you know what before we get
into pull it up well first off what's it
like working with someone tell me how
you met actually I go a little bit I
know a little bit about it I'm asking 17
questions that one a little bit about
how you met how you started working
together and then what actually guys
came up with yeah we are saying we have
to come up with a better meeting story
yeah he was cruising women's college he
came for one party at my undergraduate
college and that was it yeah yeah and
you know working together was really
interesting because on the one hand it
can be very very challenging on the
other hand you really get to know
someone at a different level than you
could ever imagine because you're
functioning in this very very abstract
space where I found that each of us was
bringing
our own intuition honed in a very
different context so that sometimes he'd
say something that I'd know just
intuitively from understanding the
economics couldn't be correct and
sometimes I'd say something that he'd
know couldn't be correct from the mat
but you know we were in very very
abstract space when we were talking
about this you really get to see the
inner workings of someone's mind in a
way that's really incredible and it's
something that I'm so glad we were able
to do and you know we still talk about
many issues together we're not working
as much on the technical stuff now yeah
but let's talk a little bit about the
technical stuff sure so he and I worked
together on a project where we were
using gauge theory which is a kind of
calculus to look at some issues in
economics and so when I talked a little
bit earlier about how economics allows
you to bring a physics metric to looking
at humans it can but the problem is
sometimes the math we use is limited
enough that it's forced economists to
make some very unwell incorrect
assumptions so the case that we were
working on was where we were looking at
measures of the economy so the Consumer
Price Index or GDP measures so measuring
inflation or growth and what we found
was the assumption that economists had
placed was that we have to assume the
preferences don't change in order for us
to actually be able to come up with an
index that makes sense and it turns out
that if you're working with standard
calculus it is very hard to do an index
number that allows you to have changing
preferences but if you shift using gauge
theory in fact you can develop an index
which comes close to well which actually
accurately keeps track of an
individual's utility so the actual the
actual growth in a person's consumption
basket or what the actual inflation is
that a person experiences given the
basket that they were
zooming so you know when it was very
very interesting work theoretically and
then it had this very strong real-world
application the problem was the timing
was just really bad because we were
working on issues of inflation right
about the time that to Senator is back
backward and Moynihan had put together
Commission to try and adjust the way we
calculate CPI and it was really
interesting how the same came about
because what they realized was that
Social Security was going to be in
trouble and they wanted a way to cut
back on Social Security but it's very
clear that Social Security is a third
rail right now you cannot touch it
because politically it's suicide so they
figured out this ingenious backdoor
where they said if we point out that the
Consumer Price Index is actually
overvalued that the way we're
calculating it is incorrect and we scale
it back and specifically if we scale it
back by saying that we have we are
miscalculating by 1.1 percent we can
save a trillion dollars over ten years
so they got a group of economists
together with the hope that they would
find that the CPI was in fact overvalued
and it just so happened that one of the
people on this commission two of the
people on this commission were the
Harvard Economics Department right when
I was writing my thesis and you know I
was this naive graduate student and I
would walk into video Jorgensen's office
and say guess what I've got this great
way to calculate the CPI and he took one
look at the same he's like you got
nothing get out of here and you know I
ended up working with Eric Maskin who
later won a Nobel Prize for a more
theoretical work and he loved it and
then he met with date with Dale
Jorgenson and then came back and said no
it's not going to work and you know when
I talk about the economics of economics
and I talk about the incentive
structures of economists to me this was
really initiation by fire very quickly
how the field actually works and
what is driving academic knowledge
within this field yeah boy there's so
much richness there I feel that we
should go personal for the for the last
questionnaire because we can talk to
economic theory all day long so what is
it like to be I mean you guys are sort
of an intellectual powerhouse couple
that's got a that's got to be kind of
interesting you must meet all sorts of
interesting people constantly be having
those those discussions how do you
remain adorable people I mean we've got
to know each other now and have had
dinners and things I mean how do you you
know just not how do you get out of that
world together sometimes I don't know we
go hiking we go swimming we go biking
we're normal people that we have really
interesting dinner table conversations
so it's it's just what life is indeed
we're having dinner tonight for you so
looking forward is going to be a really
interesting dinner conversation well
it's been an absolute pleasure talking
to you I'm glad we finally did this and
you know I realize that you got on
Twitter just in the last leg hours
something do you even know what your
Twitter name is I think it's p.m. Avani
just saying I that's correct
all right well if Pia is right it's just
ask Pia Milani and and if not or even if
she is we're going to link down to a big
think video that she did that I think
captures a lot of what we've talked
about in some stuff that we didn't quite
get to and thanks for watching we'll do
it again next week
[Music]
you